it was meant to be a rally to support
niger's co-leaders
but it turned into a violent protest
against France with some demonstrators
storming the French Embassy in the army
the French government is condemned the
coup
and the attack on its diplomatic
compound
I would like to say to the European
Union the African Union and ecowas
please stay out of our business
the French flag was replaced by another
flag of the same colors
Russia
support for the Kremlin has been gaining
momentum in West Africa
Leisure School leaders called the
protest in the face of imminent military
action from the ecowas regional block
[Music]
the objective of this meeting is to
agree a plan of aggression against Niger
through an imminent military
intervention in Miami in collaboration
with African nations not members of the
organization and certain Western
countries
at an emergency Summit of the economic
community of West African States in
Abuja strong words from its chairman and
Nigeria's president Bola tinebu
only calamity
is an assault
on every one of holes
and we
must take a very strong action
the regional block has given these years
School leaders and ultimatum either
release and reinstate deposed president
Muhammad bazum in one week or for his
military action
on the sidelines of the summit the
leaders met charts president who offered
a proposal
but the leaders here couldn't even wait
for the outcome of the mediation
in the event the authorities demands are
not met within one week
take all measures necessary to restore
constitutional order in the Republic of
Niger
such measures may include the use of
force
to this effect the Chiefs the chiefs of
different staff of ecowas are to meet
immediately diplomats from the United
States the European Union and the United
Nations attended the summit you know us
and the entire United Nations system
remain available to work closely with
ecowas Echo has also announced eruptive
measures including the closure of air
and land borders with Niger freezing the
country's Assets in Regional and
Commercial Banks but there is no mention
of who will pay for any possible
military intervention it's not clear if
this is enough to force the military
government in Asia to reverse their
actions
Abuja
and guiricelli is a former French
diplomat and she says military
intervention isn't in anyone's interests
but that ecowas needs to show it can
influence the situation
the ecowas is creating its own Regional
Force at the end of
2022 and so the it would be the first
time that uh they will use this option
as uh
let's say uh threatening for military
action because they have this new tool
so they have to show that they can they
they have power to to to influence the
the political situation with this tool
and to also better show that they have a
legitimacy and also the the the means to
to to have an impact on this crisis